في أعماق غابات أذربيجان ،
توجد طيور الدببة ومطعم حيث
يوجد أيضًا فريق endo kazuto-san Bill
حتى المساء ، كان Billina is
foliate افتراضًا كان مسافر Mamba
despierte و Yeol عرض أو أخبره
جيدًا بشكل خاص لذلك حصل هذا المطعم
على رؤية  لكي تعمل
هذه القصة الكبيرة العظيمة ، أصبح ممكنًا
بفضل شركة السياحة الأذربيجانية كوبلر كريموف
هو صاحب مطعم kabbalah con la
بمجرد أن أنشأ متجرًا ، أصبح أيضًا
حامي الغابات الذي يسرق فصلي من
مفوضياتي ، المعلم مهراجا ،
الشماعات البسيطة للمشكلة هي رمز
لجميع الأعضاء  من Cabal Australia ، هذا
هو موس الشعر AF بدأ التدريب
مع Con la عندما كان طاهًا شابًا
وهو يعرف الطعام الجيد ،
ولكن من Gloria بدأ في ذلك ، لذا فإن
رئيس مختبري سوزي يقطع اللحم على
جذع شجرة هو كيف يصنع له  توقيع
kabobs you multi DuPont الكثير من المتاعب
تخشى أن يكون الرجل قد فعلك بشكل أفضل
طلبًا بشأن الميزانية ، وهنا أيضًا
يجعل Sasha Rossi طبق الراعي الذي
كان طويلاً  rgotten حتى تدخل con لار
في ذلك عن طريق طهي اللحم بين لوحين
حجريين ، أزعج داوسون سكيبتا
بادانج بالصورة الوطنية
لوزير فيرجن على الأساس المنطقي
لهذين الرجلين ، والسر وراء هذه المغامرة لتناول الطعام
هو القراءة البسيطة التي ذكرها
فقر الدم باستثناء جاكرتا صن  ابنة موهابا كوليران ،
توم أوه أم دوت أنقذتك ، يجب أن
أقول إن صالون الحل استمتعت بـ
Nagala Jen. سأبتسم بينما تحصل على
قشعريرة أنابيل الفوضوية في المرآب ، تعلم
أنها صدمة مستمرة في مانهاتن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]